[Music]
India which is in its shape
quadrilateral has its Eastern as well as
its western side bounded by the Great
Sea but on the northern side is divided
by Mount Hema Dawa and that part of
Sathya which is inhabited by the
recipients who were called the Sakai
while the fourth or western side is
bounded by the river called the Indus
which is perhaps the largest of all the
rivers in the world after the Nile the
extent of the whole country from east to
west is said to be twenty-eight thousand
stadia and from north to south 32,000
being thus of such a vast extent it
seems well nigh to embrace the whole of
the northern tropic zone of the earth
and in fact at the extreme point of
India the son died or may frequently be
observed to cast no shadow while the
constellation of the bear is by night
invisible consequently with this is also
stated that shadows there fall to the
southward it is said that India being of
enormous size when taken as a whole is
peopled by races both numerous and
diverse which not even one was
originally of foreign descent but all
were evidently indigenous and moreover
the India neither received a colony from
abroad nor sent out a colony to any
other nation
the legends further inform us that in
primitive times the inhabitants
subsisted on such fruits as the earth
yielded spontaneously as was the case
with the Greeks and that in like manner
as with them the arts and other
appliances which improve human life were
gradually invented
the whole population of India is divided
into seven castes of which the first is
formed by the collective body of the
philosophers which in point of number is
inferior to the other classes but in
point of dignity preeminent overall for
the philosophers being exempted from all
public duties are neither the Masters
nor the servants of others they are
however engaged by private persons to
offer the sacrifices due in lifetime and
to celebrate the obsequies of the dead
for they are believed to be the most
dear to the gods and to be the most
conversant with matters pertaining to
Hades in requital of such services they
receive valuable gifts and privileges to
the people of India at large they also
render great benefits when gathered
together at the beginning of the year
they forewarn the assembled multitude
about droughts and wet weather and also
about propitious winds and diseases and
other topics capable of profiting the
Haris the philosopher who errs in his
predictions incurs no other penalty but
silence
this video has been made possible by the
great two courses plus the online
learning resource the great courses plus
has been a long-time supporter of
content from the history brothers for a
while now and they're excellent
university level courses are something
we also turn to when we need to learn
about something a great recent example
of this has been for our new channel the
entire history of the earth me and Pete
needed to get up to speed with the
latest science so we turned to the 48
part course the origin and evolution of
Earth by Professor Robert M Hazen a
fascinating in-depth look at the deep
history of our incredible planet so with
over 11,000 courses to choose from that
you can enjoy whenever and wherever you
want it's a great choice to increase
your knowledge about any given subject
head over to the great courses plus com
forward slash voices or click the link
in the description to start your free
trial now thanks the second cast
consists of the husband's men who appear
to be far more numerous than the others
being moreover exempted from the
fighting and other public services they
devote the whole of their time to
tillage nor was an enemy coming upon a
husband man at work on his land to do
him any harm for men of this class being
regarded as public benefactors are
protected from all injury the land thus
remaining unraveled and producing heavy
crops supplies the inhabitants with all
that is requisite to make life very
enjoyable the husbandmen themselves with
their wives and children live in the
country and entirely avoid going to town
they pay a land tribute to the king
because all India is the property of the
crown and no private person is permitted
to own land
[Music]
the third cast consists of these
shepherds and in general of all herdsmen
who neither settle in towns or in
villages but live in tents by hunting
and trapping they clear the country of
noxious birds and wild beasts as they
apply themselves eagerly and assiduously
to this pursuit they free India from the
pests with which it abounds all sorts of
wild beasts and birds which devour the
seeds sown by the husbandmen the forth
cast consists of the artisans of these
some are Armorer's while others make the
implements which husbandmen and others
find useful in their different callings
this class is not only exempted from
paying taxes but even receives
maintenance from the Royal Exchange and
gives itself up to idleness and
amusement in times of peace the entire
force men-at-arms war horses war
elephants and all are maintained at the
Kings expense the sixth cast consists of
the overseers it is their province to
inquire into and superintend all that
goes on in India and make report to the
king or where there is not a king to the
magistrates these seventh cast consists
of the councillors and Assessors it is
the smallest cast looking to number but
it is the most respected on account of
the high character and wisdom of its
members for from their ranks the
advisors of the King are taken and the
treasurer's of the state and the
arbiters who settle disputes the
generals of the army also and the chief
magistrates usually belong to this class
such then or about the parts into which
the body politic in India is divided no
one is allowed to marry out of his own
caste or to exercise any calling or art
except his own for instance a soldier
cannot become a husband man or an
artisan a philosopher among the Indians
officers are appointed even for
foreigners whose duty is to see that no
foreigner is wronged should any of them
lose his health
they sent physicians to attend him and
take care of him otherwise and if he
dies they bury him and deliver over such
property as he leaves to his relatives
the judges also decide cases in which
foreigners are concerned with the
greatest care and come down sharply on
those who take unfair advantage of them
India as many huge mountains which
abound in fruit trees of every kind and
many vast plains of great fertility more
or less beautiful but all alike
intersected by a multitude of rivers the
greater part of the soil moreover is
under irrigation and consequently
there's two crops in the course of the
year it teams at the same time with
animals of all sorts beasts of the field
and fowls of the air of all different
degrees of strength and size there are
monkeys rollers of rocks which climb
precipices whence they roll down stones
upon their pursuers it is also said that
there exists in India a one horned
animal cooled by the natives the Carters
on it is over the size of a full-grown
horse and has a crest and yellow hair
soft as wool it is furnished with very
good legs and is very fleet its legs are
jointless and formed like those of the
elephant and it has a tail like a
swine's a horn sprouts out from between
its eyebrows and this is not straight
but curved into the most natural reeds
and is of a black color it is said to be
extremely sharp this horn the animal as
I learned has a voice beyond all example
loud ringing and dissonant it allows
other animals to approach it and is
good-natured towards them it is prolific
besides in elephants which are of
monstrous bulk as its soil supplies food
in unsparing profusion making these
animals far exceeding in strength than
those that have bred in Libya it results
also that since they are caught in great
numbers by the Indians and trained for
war they are of great moment in turning
the scale of victory the inhabitants in
like manner having abundant means of
subsistence exceed in consequence the
ordinary stature and are distinguished
by their proud bearing
they're also found to be well skilled in
the arts as might be expected of men who
inhale a pure air and drink the very
finest water and while the soil bears on
its surface all kinds of fruits which
are known to cultivation
it has also underground numerous veins
of all sorts of metals for it contains
much gold and silver and copper and iron
in no small quantity and even tin and
other metals which are employed in
making articles of use and ornament as
well as the implements and accoutrements
of war the Indians all live frugally
especially when in camp they dislike a
great undisciplined multitude and
consequently they observe good order
theft is of a very rare occurrence
megasthenes says that those who were in
the camp of sand ricotta's wherein lay
four hundred thousand men found that the
thefts reported on any one day did not
exceed the value of two hundred two
drachma and this among a people who have
no written laws but are ignorant of
writing and must therefore in all
business of life trust to memory they
live never less happily enough being
simple in their manners and frugal they
never drink wine except at sacrifices
their beverage is a liqueur composed
from rice instead of barley and their
food is principally a rice pottage the
simplicity of their laws and their
contracts is proved by the fact that
they seldom go to law they have no suits
about pledges or deposits nor do they
require either seals or witnesses but
make their deposits and confide in each
other the houses and property they
generally leave unguarded these things
indicate that they possess good sober
sense but other things they do which one
cannot approve for instance
they always eat alone and that they have
no fixed hours when meals are to be
taken by all in common but each one eats
when he feels inclined the contrary
custom would be better for the ends of
social and civil life their favourite
mode of exercising the body is
by friction applied in various ways but
especially by passing smooth evany
rollers over the skin their tools are
plain and the mounds raised over the
dead lowly in contrast to the general
simplicity of their style
they love finery and ornament their
robes are worked in gold and ornamented
with precious stones and they were also
flowered garments made of the finest
muslin attendants walking behind hold up
umbrellas over them for they have a high
regard for beauty and avail themselves
of every device to improve their looks
truth and virtue they hold alike in
esteem hence they Accord no special
privileges to the old unless they
possess superior wisdom they marry many
wives whom they buy from their parents
giving in exchange a yoke of oxen some
they marry hoping to find in them
willing help mates and others for
pleasure and to fill their houses with
children the wives prostitute themselves
unless they are compelled to be chaste
no one wears a crown at her sacrifice or
libation and they do not stab the victim
but strangle it so that nothing is
mutilated but only what is in Tyre may
be presented to the deity the King
departs for the chase in back an alien
fashion crowds of women surround him and
outside this circle sphere man arranged
the road is marked off with ropes and it
is death for man and woman alike to pass
within the ropes men with drums and
gongs lead the procession the King hunts
in the enclosures and shoots arrows from
a platform at his side
stand two or three armed women if he
hunts in the open grounds he shoots from
the back of an elephant of the women
some are in chariots some are on horses
and some even on elephants and they are
equipped with weapons of every kind as
if they are going on a campaign these
customs are very strange when compared
with our own but the following are still
more so forma Gaston ease states that
the tribes inhabiting the Caucasus have
intercourse with women in
public and eat the bodies of their
relatives but deviating into fables who
says there are men five spans and even
three spans in height some of whom want
to the nose having only two orifices
above the mouth through which they
breathe
according to megasthenes on a mountain
called new low their live men whose feet
to turned backward and who have eight
toes on each foot while on many of the
mountains there lives a race of men
having heads like those of dogs who are
clothed with the skin of wild beasts
whose speeches barking and who being
armed with claws lived by hunting and
fouling he speaks also of a race living
on the very confines of India on the
east near the source of the Ganges the
astone me who have no mouth who cover
the body which is all over hairy with
the soft down found upon the leaves of
trees and who live merely by breathing
and the perfume inhaled by the nostrils
they eat nothing and they drink nothing
they require merely a variety of odors
of roots and flowers and of wild apples
[Music]